je vous ai dit tout à l'heure que le
canada possède est quelque chose de très
particulier qu'on appelle les sables
bitumineux les sables bitumineux c'est
donc un pétrole plus vieux du pétrole
mélangé à du sahara blain donc ça
s'exploite de la manière suivante vous
allez avec une grosse pelleteuse prendre
le contenu de ce que vous avez dans le
sol ou sous le sol vous mettez ça dans
une énorme chaudière est en gros vous
fait sortir avec de la vapeur
la fraction bitumineuse liquéfié à haute
température de ce truc là et après vous
avez un hydrocarbure lourd que vous
allez craquer raffiné auquel vous allez
rajouter d'hydrogène et c'est pire finir
par obtenir des trucs qui font avancer
les voitures et voler les avions si vous
regardez quelles sont les réserves
prouvées du canada en ce qui concerne
ces sables bitumineux
eh bien vous voyez que ça le met
quasiment au niveau de l'iran ou de
l'arabie saoudite
et là vous avez aussi une partie de
l'explication du revirement récent du
canada en ce qui concerne toujours ce
fameux protocole de kyoto c'est à dire
qu'avant il avait pris des engagements
contraignants
l'exploitation de ce truc là ça crache
plein de co2 ça ramène plein de dollars
qui sont des pétrodollars bon dollar et
donc le canada aujourd'hui traîne
beaucoup plus les pieds commence à dire
oui peut-être que kyoto finalement
c'était pas une très bonne idée et c'est
enfin c'est surtout les gens du milieu
la seconde pétrole les québécois c'est
moins qu'à mais vous avez là une partie
de l'explication du revirement du canada
sur la scène diplomatique mondiale dans
le cadre des négociations qu'il a
l'argent mène le monde
là comme ailleurs